our car tester sasha knopf says that he
may have the right car for people who
have a country house in tuscany
the amg version of the mercedes s-class
coupe
it retails for a hefty 170 000 euros
and will be checking what sort of luxury
that money will buy you
some cars are simply a joy to be in and
the new mercedes s63 amg
coupe is one of them the s-class sedan
is a car to be driven around in the
coupe is one to drive yourself
the back seats leave room for little
more than a briefcase but this car is
about the front
not the back the extreme power of the
engine is guaranteed to put a smile on
any serious driver's face
mercedes has reduced the weight of the
new model by 65 kilos
even though the s63 amg coupe has more
standard options
than its predecessor that's because the
complete body shell and parts of the
chassis
are made of aluminum but the engineers
only reduced weight
where it made sense the sound proofing
in the doors for instance
has stayed the same
mercedes aerodynamics expert alexander
mercenar says
that special attention was also paid to
the side windows
they contain extra thick six millimeter
glass
it's laminated made up of two layers
separated by a transparent film
cutting down on exterior noise at the
same time
we also thought long and hard about the
seals he says
what sort of material they should be
made of and how many layers of seal
there should be
you can hear the results or to be
precise
not hear them in fact the coupe is
quieter than the sedan
for mercedes quiet is an integral part
of luxury
as is scented air in the cab something
usually only featured in french luxury
cars
the nose is after all a sensitive organ
sasha says for 170 000 euros there's a
lot of luxury in the interior and there
are plenty of buttons to control the
amenities
there are three large control areas on
the left are various driving assistance
systems
and front is the onboard navigation and
radio
and then there's the heating and air
conditioning
our car tester adds that the amg version
of the s-class coupe
delivers 430 kilowatts of power and
zooms from zero to 103.9 seconds
but the speedometer only goes up to 250
kilometers an hour
and the fuel consumption is
optimistically estimated at 10 liters
per hundred kilometers
our car tester is probably going to need
a bit more than that today
like the s-class limousine the coupe is
available with a variety of driving
assistance systems that make the car
safer and more comfortable
one example is the distronic plus with a
steering assist function
and a stop and go pilot it allows
drivers to relax in traffic jams
hitting the gas braking and staying in
lane everything is
automatic the driver just has to get
used to technology
however the car seems to react quite
sluggishly
and you can catch yourself with your
foot hovering over the brake
just in case
our car tester says that those who fall
in love with the s-class coupe
but don't have 170 000 euros for the amg
version
might want to look at the s-500 version
it only costs 126
000 euros but also has a lot to offer
it's got a top performance motor great
design inside and out
and is sure to attract jealous looks
from other drivers
you